and now for more we're joined now by the
former chairman of the fa Greg dike
lovely to have you on the program uh
good to see you here good morning thanks
for coming on
um we just had that doorstep from my
colleague James Matthews about
Manchester United now of course you used
to be a director of Manchester United I
did all the glazers took over I think
you warned at the time the Takeover
wasn't in the interest of the club are
you pleased to see the back of them oh I
think all Manchester United fans will be
pleased to see the back of them I think
they've
some of what question uh Christian
Ronaldo said this week was I thought
quite interesting when he basically said
look going back there after 15 years the
ground has deteriorated the training
ground has deter it I think they haven't
spent the money on the club and they've
done it because they've been taking
a large amount of money out now having
said that football fans would always
want uh
money to stay in the club and not and
not be paid out to shareholders so but I
do think I think Manchester United fans
generally will be celebrating today I
was interested to hear you mentioned the
Ronaldo interview then you agreed with
some of what he said
well I thought his point about
what's happened to the club over a
period of years I mean there's no doubt
the money has not been invested I mean
Old Trafford used to be you know around
ahead of its time it's no longer like
that the training ground is no longer
the world catches up and you have to
spend capital and they haven't spent it
they've taken the money out I just
wonder if there's a bigger Point here as
well not just about Old Trafford you
know in Germany for example they've got
rules to stop a single owner having too
much dominance in controlling clubs
supporters have a much greater role as
well you know is there an issue with
English clubs you know they can be
bought and sold almost like second-hand
cars oh I think there is and then
there's no doubt uh I mean in Germany 51
is owned by the fans it was interesting
that when the European Super League came
up there were no German clubs there
involved because their fans didn't want
that
um I
you I think you've got to look at what's
happened to English who's buying it I
mean my my position is increasingly the
premier league has become to be
dominated by Foreign owners foreign
managers foreign players and so you
think something needs to change what
what do you think should change and who
should find well I think we're I think
we might be too late oddly in terms of
ownership uh I mean if if the glaciers
sell the club uh for four or five
billion pounds this is what people
talking about then whoever buys it is
going to want some sort of return on
their money they're bound to but you
could change the rules though right
uh it's very difficult to change the
rules if if clubs have changed for that
sort of money how do you change them the
fa can't change it would require uh a
law I think you could say
easily make it that there have to be
fans Representatives on the board I
think that would be good I mean I'm
involved I've been involved with
Brentford which are her now Premier
League club and uh they're fans
Representatives on the board wonderful
Club I've been to a few games at
Bradford I have to say it's well it's I
was chairman for a while for quite a
long while but I was chairman in the
days when we used to have a whip round
to pay the wages today it's brilliantly
run and uh I think it's it's a big
success story yeah definitely I'm Keen
to talk to you about the World Cup uh as
well
um what are you making the decision to
hold it in Qatar
well it was always a ridiculous decision
and it was corrupt basically I mean you
know you have to accept that most of the
people who voted for Qatar
uh or or the executive who voted for it
um most of them were driven out of
football because for corrupt reasons for
corruption uh I it was a bad decision it
didn't meet I mean the FIFA's own Safety
Committee recommended strongly against
it which is why in the end it had to be
moved from the summer to the winter it
isn't big enough it hasn't got you know
if you wanted to put a a World Cup in
the Middle East first of all you'd have
had to accept that it wasn't going to
play in the summer but secondly you'd
have done it through four or five
countries you wouldn't put it you know
the sixth stadium in one city it's an it
was a silly decision I think and that's
with before you get into all the other
issues yeah yeah you talk about
obviously the concerns about women's
rights about um LGBT rights as well and
we're going to be talking about Laura
McAllister to Laura McAllister shortly
who was ordered to remove her rainbow
bucket hat when she went in to watch a
whales game there
um I'm just interested why would they do
I mean that that's just a stupid thing
to do to get a lot of publicity for
something they're embarrassed about
anyway what do you make of the because
obviously there was there was a talk
wasn't there that you know Kane and
others would wear the rainbow armband
they then back down because they would
get a yellow card for it what did you
make of that
well it had to be better organized than
it was if the six or seven European
countries that were doing it had all
felt so strongly about it they could
have said to FIFA
we're doing this and if you don't like
it we're all out of it
and FIFA is not a brave organization but
I mean if you can pick one off after the
other which is what it did it wasn't a
problem but I think if the seven
countries are good the FAS of those
seven countries have got together and
said look we're this is what we are
doing FIFA would have had to have backed
out has it spoiled your ability to enjoy
the World Cup
um not really I enjoy watching football
uh so I and I have watched quite a lot
of games I don't think yet it's a great
world couples but it you know it's very
early days
um
in terms of the football
I I do think
it was a poor decision by it by FIFA and
the original decision and I do think
that is tarnished uh the World Cup this
time and I I would think FIFA who is now
under different sort of management I
think FIFA must be just hoping it's
waiting for it to be over so they can
get back to normal and normal will be
America and Canada is there anyone any
team in particular got your eye on then
who do you think has got the best chance
of winning it
when I when I was chairman of the vfa I
set England the target of winning in in
Qatar uh I don't think that's impossible
although I think the fence looked pretty
dangerous yeah uh and Brazil looked
pretty good yeah so you think that it's
not impossible then for England oh no I
think England England uh I mean I had a
very good first game a very average
second game but that's all right
everybody has an average game they
didn't lose uh and I have I I I I think
the manager is very good and I think
they've got to live in with the chance I
think they can well be you know living
with they're one of sort of four clubs
four four countries I think who could
win it now you obviously used to be
director general of the BBC and just
with that hat on I mean there's been a
lot of political debate recently about
the license fee you know the current
culture secretary Michelle Donald
previously dubbed it an unfair tax do
you think it is well it's always been an
unfair tax in the sense that it's
everybody pays the same regardless of
how poor how rich the problem with the
lies the issue with their license fee I
I believe in the Public Funding of the
BBC whether you can find a better way
uh than the license fee is what the
discussion needs to be about but it's
got to be a better way that doesn't give
more power for the politicians to run to
to influence the BBC is there a better
way that you can see or well I spent
many years and I think there are other
ways of funding of funding the BBC from
the public purse
um
but if you look now I personally don't
think this is a big issue now because I
do think we're in the last we're in the
dying days of of this government uh and
I think I mean my impression has always
been that the government of the day in
the end doesn't like the BBC but the
opposition does so the BBC gets a better
period when a new government comes in
and I suspect that's what's going to
happen in the next two years uh just
finally uh the upcoming Media bill also
expected to have a decision on Channel 4
privatization and what's your position
on that well there was no argument for
privatizing channel four it was a
ridiculous uh decision or thought in the
first place and then the secretary said
to had it said well they they if they
get privatized they can they can
challenge uh the big players in the
world that have emerged you know the
streamers
I that was never real the only way that
channel 4 makes any sense if you turn
into a private operation and sell it is
if it's part of something that's much
bigger and I can't see the reason for
doing that okay um really interesting to
have you on the program good to talk a
bit about football as well as important
politics show thank you